To define an orthographic camera in 3GS you do two operations. One is to define
a volume in space. The other is to move and orient that volume of space as you
wish. This first piece of code creates the orthographic camera and defines the
rectangular box of space it's viewing. This box is defined by the left to right
width limits. The top-to-bottom height limits and front-to-back limits, all in
world-space coordinates. These correspond to the x, y, and z axes. The camera
can be thought of being positioned on the plus z end of the box defined.
Looking down the minus z axis, with upting the y plus direction, as usual. For
convenience, I define a view size, which is how much vertical space I'd like to
fit in the view. The aspect ratio is just that, what's called the aspect ratio
of the window. It describes how wide the view is compared to how high it is.
For example, if your view was 1000 pixel wide and 500 high the aspect ratio
would be equal to 2. In other words you'd want your box to be twice as wide as
it is tall. If you don't, you'll get a stretch view of the world, which is
probably not what you wanted. What all this code does is defines a box in
space. In this case it happens to be centered around the origin. By the way,
I've seen some demos just use the camera's width and height directly as the
camera size. Don't do this. You're setting the camera size in your scene in
world coordinates which is most definitely not the same as the width and height
as your canvas in pixels. If we stopped here and put our drinking bird in the
scene, we'd get a side view of the bird. What we'd now like to do is position
and orient this camera in space to make a more interesting view. This code does
that. The first
[UNKNOWN]
moves the box by this amount. It's a translation. The same as for a normal
object. The camera controls code does two things. First, it sets up what sort
of mouse controller you want for the camera, if any. I came up with this custom
orbit and pan controls class, extending the orbit controls class I found in
3JS. This control keeps the camera oriented, so that the plus y axis is always
up. For a more unconstrained, but trickier to use control, the trackball
controls class could be specified instead. In either case, the next line sets
the target for the camera. The target is the location being looked at. This
defines a new z axis direction for the Camera. The Y axis kept pointing up as
best as possible. We'll talk about that later, when we look at the matrices
forming this camera. Once we've positioned this box in space it defines what
part of the scene we want to render. Whatever happens to be inside this box is
what we'll see on the screen. The z buffer is applied as usual so that objects
that are closer to the camera cover up what's behind them. This is just an
overview of the basic idea. The camera defines a chunk of space defining it's
limits and this chunk then gets positioned and oriented in space to make an
image. I'll go over this process in detail in the following lessons